Master Wayne well everything is showing
me two dozen hostiles on the third floor
whenever I drop you off on the second
I'm getting slow in my old age effort
even you got to hold die young not for
lack of trying he has the power to wipe
out the entire human race and we believe
there's even a one-percent chance that
he is our enemy we have to take it as
the absolute greatest gladiator match in
the history of the world God vs Man day
versus night you're psychotic it's a
three-syllable word for any thought too
big for little minds
now if you wouldn't like you I don't
think you've ever known a woman like me
lion America
the power can be innocent
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so final
Batman V Superman trailer I feel like
this is probably the best trailer they
dropped I wish they would have dropped
this a long time ago which is WTF right
from the start so let's break it down I
love the way that they open this with
the Batman clip like it's him on his
nightly rounds he's picked the cape and
cowl back up Alfred is flying their bat
wing which is kind of like a drone it's
kind of like that in the other Batman
movies he can remote piloted but I love
the way he takes these criminals down
now the idea they're trying to get
across is that yeah he's old but he is
still a badass if Christian Bale's
Batman as of Dark Knight Rises is a
30-something batman think of this is a
40-something batman approaching 50 just
a little over the hill in terms of
superhero age which is why Alfred takes
that jab at him none of the words for
where for trying to kill himself got a
few city miles on him but the speed with
which he takes these villains down like
this whole fight scene just maybe pump
my fist in the air this is what a
superhero movie is supposed to feel like
the superhero even if he doesn't have
superpowers is supposed to feel larger
than life and even though Batman is a
little more Krav Maga than ballet this
looks just as much like a dance as say
him dancing with Wonder Woman at this
party and we finally get to hear Wonder
Woman speak I'm so happy they're not
going with a weird voice I feel like
it's much better when you let the actors
speak with their natural voices but just
the smile on his face like yeah he knows
something special about Wonder Woman it
doesn't seem like he knows who wonder
woman is so maybe Wonder Woman is a myth
at this point in history you know maybe
around world war one when she helps out
she does something to downplay her
public image or people write her out of
history there's a number of ways to
explain why people don't know who wonder
woman is but we also get to see her
launch attack so it looks like she's
more Golden Age Superman in terms of her
power level I'm guessing she can't fly
in this universe or can't fly yet I've
seen a number of you point out that she
said something like that in interviews
but I haven't seen it so I'll just I'll
take your word for it assuming she's
more like Golden Age Superman logically
that makes sense because I guess you
want some diversity of powers like you
want Superman flying around in the air
you want wonder woman to be your tank on
the ground and you want Batman to be
ranged dps think of them as a Justice
League three-person raid right now
they'll build their raid out with more
Justice League members and future films
and they will be teasing Aquaman in this
movie in a couple other characters but I
don't know exact
actly when they're going to show up in
the film get a little back-and-forth
block shot catch Batarang Superman jumps
into the tub with naked Louis nice then
you get this really awesome record drop
moment where Batman blocks Superman's
punch with the bat suit on now why is
Superman and all of us why we so
surprised probably because this suit has
a lot of framework in it to make bat and
stronger but it also might be
constructed from Kryptonian alloys so in
the prequel comic we learned that Wayne
Enterprises has been experimenting with
Kryptonian technology they probably find
pieces of the ship so Batman suit might
be made from Kryptonian scrap metal if
you remember after the Avengers movie
how New York was destroyed there was
[ __ ] our e-tech lying all over the place
so they had that short film where
someone stole a [ __ ] our a weapon and
was using it to rob banks it's kind of
the same situation in the wake of the
Kryptonian attack there's a bunch of
Kryptonian debris that's left over so
you have Wayne Enterprises and probably
Lex Luthor experimenting with those
things trying to turn them into weapons
trying to reverse engineer things so let
me know in the comments do you think
that Batman's text suit is built from
Kryptonian scrap metal and that's how
he's able to block Superman's punch it
wouldn't be like kryptonite but it would
be stronger than anything that they
could make with earthbound material
stuff that you would normally find on
earth and if Batman can reverse engineer
Kryptonian tech that means Lex can do it
too and I know everyone's wondering
about this parody mancine here this is
probably from a nightmare sequence is
either a nightmare that Batman is having
or it's a nightmare that Wonder Woman is
having but because some of these shock
troopers have Superman symbols on their
arms I think it's Batman's nightmare is
the one percent chance that he's talking
about and I know the dark side Omega
symbol here in the ground is also from
the same scene I'm still curious to see
how Batman hallucinates dark side
without knowing that he exists the whole
pitch for Superman is what would happen
if an alien actually landed on earth so
now the earth knows that aliens exist
because of Superman so that gets them
half the way there but there's still
some dark side explaining that they have
to do cannot wait and in related news
Deadpool is dropping today i'm going to
be posting my non-spoilery review later
tonight and then i'll do an easter egg
video on friday or saturday they're
supposed to be over a hundred easter
eggs so I might not catch them all the
first time I see the movie I'm probably
have to see it two or three times
but everybody I've talked to completely
loves it so be sure and go see Deadpool
this weekend my legends of tomorrow
video will just post Friday morning so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
in the reverse flash ring giveaway is
still going on all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so a little bit
more batman be superman lots of Deadpool
this weekend I really do feel like this
is the trailer they should have posted
first it's so much better Batman V
Superman one punch in the soundtrack is
actually from the actual soundtrack of
the movie which is why it sounds so much
cooler so why he gives way for me to
post my Deadpool video you can click
here for all my Deadpool videos and you
can click here for all my Batman V
Superman videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight